kobe is speed running through the marine
ranks and might end up as admiral orange
crop at the end of the story wielding
the miramira no me there are very few
characters i have changed my mind about
as drastically as with kobe the little
annoying pink-haired harry potter
glasses were in kobe that we get to meet
at the very beginning of the story
when i first started getting into one
piece he was pretty damn annoying to me
i'm not gonna lie i was here for pirates
and epic fights and wanted to see luffy
and zorro beating people up and so even
the few episodes with kobe were already
enough for me however a few episodes
later no more no more like a few hundred
episodes more what
a thousand holy hell it's like someone
accidentally left the printer on anyways
nowadays my opinion on kobe has done a
full 180 degree turn to me in a way he
is the embodiment of great writing in
one piece and one of the most quickly
growing characters in the story and i
guess it took some time for me to grow
as a person as well to realize that hi
my name is manu thanks to you guys i'm
at the level where youtubers start
saying and doing stupid [ __ ] so i don't
know if this video gets a million views
in the first week i will dye my hair
pink
you become what you hate most i guess
like you know how people really hate on
something like writing [ __ ] on t-shirts
and stuff like that but then they end up
doing it themselves that's me but with
youtubers
i completely lost my thread here
one piece today i want to talk about
kobe's very unique role in the story
what his encounter with boy hancock
probably means for luffy and of course
you know the drill a crazy theory about
how kobe will become marine admiral
orange crab inheriting sabos and asus
miramira no me yes another dead brother
i know kobe's role in the story is one
of the most interesting and creative
ones in one piece which really says
something at first glance it might be
easy to think that kobe is supposed to
be to luffy what garb was to roger a
rival and foil in the marines
however kobe has neither the power nor
the necessary presence in the story to
fill that role much rather it is smoker
who chases luffy from island to island
and slowly but steadily forms a bond
with him such as garp and roger did no
to me personally kobe's relationship to
luffy is much closer to the one luffy
has with shanks because he was the one
who inspired luffy to follow his dream
and even though luffy never really gets
to see shanks he keeps chasing after him
catching up in strength and experience
and the way i see it it's the same for
kobe luffy was the one who inspired him
to follow his dream to become a marine
and even though he barely ever sees
luffy he strives to catch up to him as
fast as he can he's the first and maybe
most important example of luffy's unique
ability to make friends and allies
wherever he goes and bring out the best
in people with luffy by his side kobe
goes from the small plump and cowardly
boy to the full-blown marine captain
with haki and rokushiki powers in just
two years he's still far behind luffy
but considering that luffy has been
training his entire life with garp and
ace ensemble i think it's more than
impressive how fast kobe has developed
basically he starts as a people-pleaser
with little self-esteem on aida's ship
which is of course understandable if you
want to survive who is too scared to
step out of his comfort zone to actually
chase his dream
[Music]
inspired by luffy's confidence he
finally awakens his inner flame of
courage and decides to take the
necessary steps to turn his life around
essentially kobe stops making excuses
and starts taking things into his own
hands accepting the risk that he might
fail or be rejected under garf's special
training and following luffy's quick
rise in the pirate world even though he
still is undeniably kobe every time we
see him he has more and more confidence
and power he still cries a lot but it is
completely different because instead of
self-pity and cowardness he now is a man
that simply embraces his emotional side
and is as caring and kind to people as
any straw hats again in true luffy
fashion his new big dream is to become a
marine admiral mirroring luffy's dream
to become pirate king
luffy keeps inspiring kobe that anything
is possible however it's only from here
that things really start to heat up
marine for then is of course a true
milestone in this development the moment
he was determined enough to step in
front of akainu the coldest and most
unforgiving marine out there well
knowing that it will probably cost him
his life but with zero regrets was when
kobe gained 20 000 extra respect points
in my book and in years probably as well
just like luffy he is now prepared to
embrace his values and ideals and offer
his life for them in that moment he is
the ultimate contrast to the cruel
warmongering of a kainu and shows us
what the marines could and let's be real
should be like something for which he
even earns the respect of shanks himself
he just keeps rising through the ranks
and now is holding the sixth highest
position in the countless marine ranks
taking on more and more important tasks
not only is he now on the way to fight
the former warlord boa hancock but he is
also part of the secret marine
organization sword that actively is
fighting to free the marines from the
hand of the corrupt world governments to
my eyes at least oda is clearly building
kobe up to play some important role in
the story on the one hand he shows us
how great and special a person luffy
truly is planting the seeds of
friendship with a future top marine in
the second chapter of the story to me
this makes kobe a personification
of the effect that luffy has on other
people on the other hand he is now
imitating luffy on the marine side and
is being set up as one of the
quote-unquote proper ones that will lead
the navy on the right path once the
world government is taken down an
absolutely fantastic supporting
character that is written very
unconventionally but that i absolutely
have grown to love so where does our
pink-haired bad boy go from here the
abolishment of the shichibukai system
was one of the major outcomes of the
reverie and threw a lot of heavy hitters
back into the game i can tell you how
excited i am to see where mihawk is
going to end up buggy is surely gonna
run into luffy again at some point as
well but the most interesting storyline
right now is undoubtedly boa hancock's
confrontation with kobe
[Music]
the scared kid from the east blue versus
the revered pirate empress now the
outcome of this battle is heavily
debated after all both are pretty damn
powerful kobe has shown us how much
stronger he has gotten while hancock is
even able to use congress hockey but of
course the only thing that combines this
unlikely duo is their love for luffy
hancock is the self-declared future wife
of the pirate king while kobe is the
biggest member of the luffy fan club
second only to barcelona
i am more than curious to see how this
fight is going to turn out but i'm
convinced that sooner or later both of
them will realize that they're actually
on the same side on luffy's side and i
don't put it past either of them to team
up and come for luffy's aid maybe even
still in wano however what i think is
even more fun to think and speculate
about is whether kobe will actually
fulfill his big dream and become a
marine admiral by the end of the story
and there's actually a super interesting
theory about this that exists in a
number of different variations and with
different twists so it's kind of hard to
figure out who took credit for this
originally nonetheless it's incredibly
fun and makes surprisingly much sense i
feel now as i premise for this theory we
of course have to assume that kobe will
actually become an admiral at some point
and i think you could say against that
that he still seems to have a long way
to go but then the rate at which he has
been growing has been pretty damn insane
plus we don't know if there might not be
another time skip somewhere ahead of us
the biggest clue however lies in the
fact that this is kobe's declared dream
kobe mirrors luffy and one piece is a
story about dreams so while at the end
of the story oda could simply go and be
like oh yeah you're gonna be an admiral
when you're a big boy and they lived
heavily ever after why bring it up in
the first place so i do think that kobe
will fulfill his dream just like each of
the straw hats will fulfill theirs the
basis of this theory is the pattern that
oda uses to create the admirals in one
piece as you know each admiral has a
color associated with the devil fruit
power as well as an animal thus with the
original trio we have the red dog akainu
the blue pheasant aokiji and the yellow
monkey kizaru
later we get the purple tiger fujitora
as well as the green bull ryokugyu
another common pattern is the number
three there are always three admirals
nevermore and nevertheless now based on
that alone it would be pretty hard to
figure out more about kobe and his
future in the marines however there are
actually two more patterns hidden in
this system that you're maybe not
familiar with the first of these is the
color system now it might seem a bit
random at first but red blue and yellow
are actually the three primary colors
that you can use to make any other color
width i actually love design and stuff
so i'm pretty excited that we're talking
about color theory now now let's mix
each of these primary colors together
red and blue gives us purple blue and
yellow gives us green and red and yellow
gives us orange now aokiji and kainu
have already been replaced by green and
purple kizaru still remains but
following this pattern would be replaced
by an orange admiral as well
and so under the assumption that this is
gonna be kobe this would make him the
orange
what exactly and you may or may not
believe me but there actually is a
pretty clear pattern to the animal theme
within the admirals as well as a
one-piece fan you're already familiar
with the legend of momotaro from my
video momonosuke but in case you forgot
here's a quick refresher basically it's
an old japanese story about a boy who on
his journey to defeat an oni meets a
pheasant a dog a monkey and then in the
second phase of the story a tiger and
later on a bull during the second part
the monkey picks up and plays with a
crab that then goes on to defend itself
so the dog jumps in and tries to kill
the crab but fails to instead it can
only throw the crab with its mouth and
knock it unconscious later on this crab
or another one comes back and attacks
the dog during the final phases of the
story of momotaro now for full
disclosure this is only one of the many
variants of the story that exists that
is however particularly prominent in the
south of japan where oda is also from
the order in which each animal appears
corresponds perfectly with that of each
admiral in the story so once we have met
admiral greenball i believe we will meet
admiral orangecrap who is gonna be none
other than kobe himself sounds way more
reasonable than orange crab should am i
right i feel the exact same way but it
all seems to fit really nicely a bit too
nicely almost the two conflicts between
the dog and the crap might tell us more
about this let's just go back to this
scene here for a moment
kobe steps up to a kind of a clear clash
in morals and codes of justice a kind
who tries to kill kobe but fails in the
end only knocking him unconscious just
like the crap as shanks is stepping in
who uses his shell his haki to defend
against akainu's logia abilities a bit
too much coincidence don't you think and
this would also foreshadow a rematch
between kobe and akainu this time on the
same level now what we still need to
figure out is what ability kobe might
have that would coincide with the orange
theme i mean if kobe becomes an admiral
he needs a devil fruit to back it up
there are probably more options out
there but the best one that comes to
mind is subscribing to my channel for
next generation anime contents and the
second best is asus miramira no me that
is as orange as it gets ace even has a
direct connection to a kainu lake as
direct as it gets
now the only problem with this is
obviously that sabo has already eaten
asus fruit sabo who fights with claws
just as a crap
now if only there was any sign that sabo
might not survive and lose his fruit
ability to someone else
the reverie really turned that idea on
its head for me if sabo now was in
comparable trouble to ace that might
lead to his death or who knows maybe he
already has died then who better for
luffy to inherit both of his brother's
wills than kobe but hey that's just a
theory a one-piece theory and if you do
want to know why kobe could actually
inherit asus and sabo's will by eating
their devil fruit i strongly recommend
you watch exactly that video right here